un autre prix a été remis pendant les
vacances à un très jeune danseur son nom
patrick dupont il a remporté le grand
prix de varna événement exceptionnel
surtout pour un jeune danseur français
quand on sait la valeur qui s'attache à
ce prix patrick dupond 17 ans kadri de
l'opéra il vient de remporter le grand
prix du festival international de danse
de varna un triomphe éclatant puisque ce
prix n'a été attribué que deux fois
depuis la fondation du concours en 1964
de la graine des toiles dit on déjà
[Musique]
et
ap
mon
[Musique]
ça fait sept ans et demi qui est mis
pour la première fois chez moi c'était
un petit garçon qui avait envie de faire
de la danse limite chez moi il espérait
faire des pointes alors la première
chose que je lui ai dit ça jamais de
pointe c'est fini alors il était très
déçu
il fallait une pu revenir de thrombine
si le devine espérer que faire du point
vous avez pensé tout de suite qu'il
avait des qualités exceptionnelles et me
suis intéressé à lui parce que de la
danse
il y avait pire que d'hommes l opéra
qu'ils ont de faire de la danse en
professionnel et j'avais senti que cette
année nuance très particulier
ces essais dans ma vie c'est ça devait
être écrit avant que je sois né mais je
suis né pour vivre de la danse et tu
peux pas m'en passer
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
êtes vous surpris d'avoir un peu du
grand prix de barnard a très vite
pourtant parce que je suis parti tout à
fait vite évidemment en espérant va
décrocher une médaille décrochée quelque
chose mais qu'on me donne le grand prix
de varna
quand même que seuls de grands danseurs
les plus grands danseurs du monde russe
est quelque chose de très grand et puis
quand même en général quand rien danseur
russe qui a tient contient un prix qui
obtient une médaille d'or un concours de
gens ne sont pas très étonné mais la
france est un dupont c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire
quels sont vos projets maintenant pas
très sains mais projet c'est dans ces
beaucoup dansé et puis j'aimerais bien
lancé un grand pas de vous voyez sur une
grande scène en fin de carrière mondiale
jouera faire déjà celle de l'opéra au
premier je crois que c'est déjà fin de
noël
[Musique]